[Musique]
je vais vous parler du film l'innocent
de Louis Garet écrit par lui-même et
Naila Giguet avec
rushdenberg et Noémie merlan c'est
l'histoire d'un homme Abel interprété
par le yell qui apprend que sa mère
tombe amoureuse d'un homme en prison et
pour le Garrel Un homme en prison ne
peut pas sortir de ses habitudes
d'escroquerie et de magouille pour ça il
va s'épauler de sa meilleure amie
Clémence interprétée par Noémie merlan
qui
on s’épauler tous les deux pour aider
donc la mère de Abel sauf qui va faire
la rencontre Abel de Michel
son nouveau beau-père
et de nouvelles perspectives vont
s'ouvrir à lui
[Musique]
en plus vous faites ça en famille si
nous avons
Logan nous propose un film de mélange de
différents genres nous avons une partie
film d'action nous avons film de comédie
romantique de drame existentiel lougarel
sort de ses habitudes et nous propose
une histoire belle et émouvante qui
vient de remporter d'ailleurs de César
celui du meilleur scénario original et
celui de la meilleure actrice dans un
second rôle car oui on peut le dire
Noémie merlan casse l'écran par son jeu
d'actrice on peut dire aussi que Bugarel
s'impose en tant que grand réalisateur
par ce film en sortant de ses habitudes
avec un film intemporel au réalisme très
humain
[Musique]